hi nicole thank you so much
for joining us today gosh that scene is
just panic inducing
and this series solos has
just an a-list wow factor cast
and you are one of the extraordinary
members of this
show that is made up of true solo
performances
is it true you are basically acting
alone in
most of it yeah i don't i really don't
know drew how i
how i snuck into the cast first of all
that's number two
there's morgan freeman there's like
helen mirren and anthony mackey
um but yeah we all the theme is that
sort of we're in our separate world kind
of as we have been
in the last year everyone sort of feels
that um
and i basically acted alone it was it
was it was a little vulnerable
but it was one of those challenges that
i think like every actor
wants the opportunity to have and uh
i didn't run from it necessarily
i'm really excited for the show because
it has a really diverse cast
it is on subjects that we all just
contended with in ways we had no idea we
ever would
um you shot miss juneteenth in 2019
but many people had not heard of
juneteenth until
2020 when black lives matter movement
took center stage will you please talk
about the importance and significance
of that day june 19th which were
you know closely coming on um was
uh the official emancipation of the
enslaved african-americans in the united
states of america
we have the emancipation proclamation
but two and a half years later
is when the remainder of the enslaved in
galveston texas were informed that they
had in fact been
free and were allowed to you know start
a new life
i think it's an amazing moment in our
history
it's actually a moment where um the
country moved forward it's
it's it's a huge moment and i i think we
just haven't
had enough conversations about that we
talk about the pain
but this is another moment just like the
civil rights and women's lib
we we have to commemorate these sorts of
moments so that we can move forward and
just know like what the real foundations
of the country are
um so for me i hope uh
it took protests it took um seeing
you know seeing all the violence but i
hope that people
at the very least will think about what
that day might mean
and that the foundations of the nation
you know um
the way that we started the nation and
our history
is is so varied um
but our future can be even more dynamic
and
and and you know abundant and just
wonderful if we take into account all of
those things
um and i like to do community service on
on on juneteenth spend time with family
you know grilling it's it's a lot like
july the 4th i really appreciated
everything
that you said and i'm in complete
agreement
and um an understanding
now that this will be um a very
important holiday that will be
uh more and more recognized as it
rightfully should have always been
has been but will take on new meaning
because of the protests and the loud
voices
on a lighter note a different note if
you will
i heard that uh when you were younger
before you became an actress
there was also another occupation that
you were convinced you might get into
yeah well i got some questions for you
honey
i wanted to i wanted to i thought i was
going to be a journalist
or perhaps a talk show host
um why did you want to be a journalist
at a talk show host
this is so bad i can't believe we're
talking this is so bad
i um well you know it was it was like
the 80s and 90s so it was like
phil like phil donahue and oprah and
you know there were all of these really
um like who's the father
super saucy crazy talk shows
and i guess my parents were allowing me
to watch them so i would sort of boss my
cousins around my brothers and sisters
and we would just create our own talk
shows in the living room
i love that and um well
as soon as it's safe please please
please we
come here and we can do the show
together and we could go to the news
desk and be
anchors and journalists and get our talk
show host thing on
i would absolutely love that i'm going
to hold you to that actually oh i'm
going to come
and be like she's she's i think she was
serious maybe i can actually
i'm not the kind who put stuff out there
that i don't mean i'm asking for a date
nicole
so i would love to do that thank you
nicole buhari
solos is available to stream tomorrow
on amazon prime video it's going to be
extraordinary
thank you so much nicole thank you thank
you
thank you thank you